[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right uh this is the daily live news
show
i was i was trying to both transition in
right there yeah that was great uh this
is the daily
live news show here from new rockstars
we're coming to july from our los
angeles headquarters our actual break
room here at new rockstars we're
thrilled to have you um today we're
going to be talking namor news some
joker 2 news might even talk a little
bit about hulu's prey yeah and of course
we'll be talking ironheart riri williams
uh some other cool news coming out of
there joining me on the uh illustrious
panel oh we're drinking already uh
already satiated we've got tommy bechdol
hey i'm feeling wet
in the chair oh boy okay they're an
inside joke that you guys will never
know about uh
coy yeah
both here holding down that that half of
the table and my name's zach uh we're
all thrilled to be here i just want to
say real quick anybody that caught
yesterday's episode um i hope you didn't
and if you did if you were a part of
yesterday's episode you should be
ashamed of yourself tommy and i are
forever changed yes um
definitely don't go back and watch it we
don't want that episode to gain any
traction on the internet i will be
honest i was coated in hot pepper dust
from my smooch to my gooch last night
i would
breathe and fight from your router to
your tutor okay oh man from his mouth
hold to his self pull uh
again uh you should be ashamed of
yourself if you contributed to you
and by the way you're gonna be put to
the test today and if i see any more
acting up with the super chats
wednesday's just going to be ice cream
sundaes again but they're all going to
be delicious
i'm done being messed with
speaking of which so yesterday some
terrible people
kept donating money on super chats
making us do bad stuff luckily none of
those people are back today and these
are only good people that are watching
today i was wrong trash day is actually
tuesday
and now there's the trash is gone yeah
we got all the classic trash bags are
out of here we're on good days ben don't
test me uh
today's redemption is all about common
sense baby particularly taste and touch
you know what i'm saying a little touch
a little taste
for every hundred dollars we raise our
sick and twisted resident chef john
has cooked up a mystery item stop
donating money
all right we're going to be blindfolded
and we have to guess correctly what this
mystery item in the bowl is everything's
edible no one's gonna die some of them
are a little disgusting if we fail to
guess you get to pick if you don't want
to taste it you can just touch it okay
the chat will decide who's gonna go once
someone correctly guesses they are out
so in the end there might just be me
putting my hands in five different bowls
crying trying to figure out what the
hell has gone wrong with my life tuesday
so once again for every hundred dollars
we raise one of us is gonna put a
blindfold on reach into a mystery bowl
or
mr feeney do not push me today
all right
we're gonna reach into a mystery bowl or
we're gonna taste something out of a
mystery bowl we have to identify what we
are tasting the main item because there
are little savory sauces there's sweet
sauces on some of the items you don't
got to get those you got to get the main
item so we're blindfolded while you put
something in our mouth that's right
what could go wrong i guess a little
history repeating itself what could go
wrong let's get to the headlines let's
get to the headlines
all right
okay samil mr feeney vrail jsp you're
off to a bad start uh but you know
what's up to a good start joker two yeah
we got some casting news yesterday we
talked a little bit about joker one
actress zazie beats kind of talking
about the film being a musical
supposedly
today we got confirmation um that she's
in tux to reprise her role as sophie
dumond in the todd phillips directed
warner brothers dc sequel joker folly i
do
follow i say
pretentious
it's probably going to be a lot of
flashbacks of like
if it takes place mainly in arkham i
think it's him being like i was in love
with the most beautiful woman that i
followed everywhere i stopped for my
apartment
her name was
and if he can imagine him
if you can imagine most of his
interactions with her the first movie
why not continue to imagine interaction
i want to point i'm very disturbed we're
already halfway to this awful awful
challenge
brianna brianna from the twisted mind of
john costa
mystery touch food mystery touch taste
food day and people like brianna harris
are sending us down a dark twisted path
shame on you uh miss marvel producer
adil l arby
uh has expressed that he would like to
see lockjaw
appear in a future miss marvel project
and i like you said future miss marvel
project not a season two necessarily
some appearance right she's gonna show
up in films probably
other series who knows a big dog um i do
love he doesn't seem like maybe the most
familiar with the character yeah he did
not refer to like jaws long time he said
she has that big dog if there's another
season or a movie
that big dog is gonna have to be a big
character right
a little dr freeze moment
sorry no
and it was worse because you were
talking to zach and i was talking to koi
uh lockjaw can jump he can it's not jump
time but he can jump through like
places right
yeah he can just go you can be somewhere
else it's like bam finger yeah that's
the sulfur so
yes yeah
is that a good idea all right i mean it
go off guys
you know he has it he appeared in the
ill-fated abc
series uh the inhumans yes like
tommy pointed out in kind of a clifford
the big red dog-esque
kind of way technology has improved yes
sounds to me like he could be in the
marbles because that would allow for
yeah because if we're gonna have her
jumping and stuck in space maybe that's
how she gets to in the comics was he
working with medusa in the comics you i
think of him as being medusa and um
right yeah he was in the family yeah
i'm a core member of the inhumans i
chopped perfectly like quarterback and
everyone all talk to him absolutely and
now it is interesting right like they've
kind of made a point so far the mcu
she's not connected necessarily with the
inhumans she's it seems like they're
trying to connect her to mutants mutant
kind whereas lockjaw is kind of like
from the uh inhumans part of things
maybe they could rewrite that too
yeah jump with you why not also he could
have prevented the whole plot of
multiverse madness maybe they won't do
it because
he didn't what what else would they
encounter there's only room for one dog
and my dog is in hawkeye that has one
eye
quick shout out to somebody actually
pitch i think that was uh brian at the
beginning of the show pitching a holiday
movie built around lucky uh the dog uh
call back to yesterday's mandatory fun
holiday movie segment um we we're
actually being fined for that segment
i'm told some of the some of the ideas
were so hot
yeah so hot they melted the snow the
youtube police are called
they're coming again whatever you do
don't go back and watch yesterday's
episode uh okay james gunn uh put to
rest some rumors about alpha groot
appearing in uh gardens of the galaxy
three now these rumors mostly stem from
vin diesel in an interview he gave while
promoting uh bloodshot which was maybe a
2020 release so he's been out there for
a minute um he said vin was actually we
have that clip let's play the the vin
diesel interview have you seen any any
scripts there we know you're going to
say i am group but what can we expect if
we see again what version of that
character are you hoping to bring to
life i
only have two words
uh about
that character and it is alpha group
i love him so unfortunately one of those
words was incorrect
[Applause]
which james against quote was uh vin was
musing out loud he hadn't read volume
three there's the quote there's the
tweet uh what you saw at comic-con was
groot in volume three and he's not alpha
group
now could be a lie that's right maybe he
doesn't want to spoil a fun surprise
like why did vin straight up say that
why would he say that two years ago he's
like all right this is the third act
he's out here we
take your best gal to the beach and just
do some group music while the sun sets
and then when the sun goes down
it goes down in the car you know what
i'm saying then you're fusing hey yo
hey yo
with my remote i'm mute groozing whoa
okay it appears that uh black panther
wakanda forever has entered reshoots we
get that we got that from my uh uh tina
huerta the neymar actor saying via
twitter that uh he has started filming
reshoots for what kind of forever
actually said he started a few weeks ago
which is just i mean this is routine for
marvel movies and it's fascinating the
trailer's already out
and they're still shooting parts of this
movie but they do that all the time on
these right they're kind of built in the
editing day as they say well it's
interesting to me that they can kind of
receive what worked and what didn't and
they can reshape and especially if
you're using like the volume or a closed
set you can go like oh test audiences
wanted more of this character and then
you can just do that it's incredible
that we live in with the advent of these
technologies you can truly let the
audience help shape the response to the
film yes and i think that can be a very
dangerous but also great thing depending
on the studio handling it yeah and we
talked about yesterday the entire
montage and thor 11 thunder of jane and
thor's relationship history like going
their breakup was all done in reshoots
right that's one of my favorite parts of
the movie yeah i mean every big movie
you know like yes
it's it's a part of the process it's
part of the life cycle of a film there's
no it's not a concern but also so
strange it's different from a lot of
hollywood history obviously and like
what a commitment for these actors like
hey uh make yourself available for like
two years okay yeah we need you free for
nine months and then six months later
for two months and then it might change
yeah it's a hell of a commitment uh
great
don't start with us today get out of
here graveyard oh what a garbage pail um
maybe jess will give me a garbage pail
kid nicknamed third day asking
garbage pill kids like the those old
friends the collectible carts yeah like
graveyard 3503 is already kind of like
yeah i like that because it would always
be like uh something normal right like
you take like
oh no i don't want to talk about it oh
oh oh
but it would be uh
it would be like you take like kid's
sister and it'd be like kid twister and
it would be like a twisted up kid
the the
depraved gourd oh that's a good one all
right samia robin you guys are awful so
robin coming to us from europe yeah
which i just want to shout that out real
quick whatever time it is there right
now you're watching us in the middle of
the night or early in the morning props
to you yeah um tommy if you want to
prepare i'll go first on the mystery
taste touch i think they're voting oh
okay sorry
i i really do appreciate that and i
would like the polls to reflect that one
candidate has volunteered to go first so
please vote for him
i'm surprised it was my first time it
was my research cold friday it was my
reverse psychology move now they'll
never pick me up um okay the uh the
actor uh tinac ortega also gave us a
little bit more insight michael's
character get out of here michael
everyone all you guys are terrible um
and it's just mean to them now i know
it's just cruelty free well because
they're being mean to us these foods
might not be the tastiest i don't know
all i could do is hear john laughing in
the kitchen as he was packaging them
cackling cackling like a little witch
there's a tina cuerta's uh quote about
about the neymar character
the character is a badass because he's
an anti-hero not a villain
that's willing to break the rules and do
what's necessary to protect his people
his culture his family in a few words he
protects his own
and again it goes on and there's like
talks a little bit about like all the
great work they did to kind of tie this
character into kind of like mythology
and like mexican culture and a lot of
that uh stuff there's some um aztec
words that i can't pronounce yeah i
threw those in there really just to feo
thank you i gave you the whole quote no
abbreviations but it is cool i mean
again
how it's also awesome neymar is a very
well known whatever 80 year old comic
book character but it kind of you know
bring him to the screen in a new
interesting way that allows for some
artistic license behind the character i
think is is dope as hell i'm really
excited and i think it's also important
that if they he's in the comics the
first mutants so we've just had the
first mutant name dropped so now we're
having our first mutants as a lead
character theoretically in november so
it'll be interesting to see how they
incorporate his part in that tapestry
and also of him being an anti-hero what
that's kind of tie into the world that
hates and fears them right because if
you've got wakanda fighting against the
atlanteans or what they're going by here
and then later on we have people fearing
mutant kind this could be the start of
oh we're afraid of the othering of them
like they're they're a different thing
that looks like us and that'd be an
interesting precedent to set as early as
november well guys great news uh i won
the poll as usual when something
terrible happened
all right we will be going first i was
eric
john if you would john if you wouldn't
mind getting one of your dark
twisted dishes i also want to point out
i watched the poll about a hundred more
people than usually vote voted in this
poll wow so i appreciate your enthusiasm
in making me do this wow
record record turnout what does this say
a
kansas uh midterm election yeah come on
the seeing is not the the thing okay
again
it's it's there's like stuff going on in
here now tell me are you going to um
oh okay so this is are you how did you
taste or do you want to do a touch i'm
gonna touch i would okay are you gonna
taste it no give them a little sniffy
poo all right it might get a little
sticky as well okay i'll i'll taste okay
okay okay open my big boy wait i want to
feed him
okay i wanted to feed him but that's
fine you guys got the kiss yesterday we
didn't we teased a kid you guys are
always getting not on camera not on
camera that's right okay ready okay
oh yeah
correct can you lean back a little bit
no i don't want to choke today i'm not
going to choke but i don't want you to
suck it on my finger oh
what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you want a second to guess what it is
like a second one no i really enjoy the
decision
oh no
[Laughter]
when is it i think you need to change it
i can't see it and i still i'm not sure
what is going on okay
it's
it's definitely a grape
okay
yeah but with
is it a thousand-year-old grape
is it a grape they found in the tomato
of a pharaoh who can confirm this john
can you tell it
okay john's gonna come in and tell us
what it is yeah i don't think i can ever
know he has to keep feeding them
so it's a grape with something on it
it's a great what's your final guess for
what i'm gonna guess it's a grape with
soy sauce on it it's you're close it
does smell like soy sauce but i believe
it is a japanese barbecue sauce on top
of a grape which yeah yeah which might
have some stuff is it is it is it pecans
no pecans japanese barbecue sauce i
don't know because i want them to
sponsor our show i don't know okay um
there's definitely barbecue sauce on
grapes you know classic combination
barbecue sauce
i have to rule that is not the correct
answer he's still tommy's name remains
in the poll okay guys awesome we will
continue all right well that was
absolutely revolting
i gotta say a lot of a lot of flavor
profiles
that i enjoy
koi turns out japanese barbecue sauce
and grapes are not one of them did you
just eat one for pleasure yeah
why did you do that
i was promised i wouldn't be tortured
two days and i was told i'd be feeding
everybody
oh my god
next headline
real quick in the chat who watched uh
pray over the weekend on hulu the new uh
predator uh film um i watched my priest
once
i prayed the whole hour
uh i watched it loved it we might have
more to talk about pray in the coming
days but let us know if you watched it
maybe if you
uh we don't know if we're gonna do a
breakdown on the channel of it but maybe
if there's enough demand um but
according to a press release 20th
century studios uh said that prey was
the number one premiere on hulu ever as
far as people that watched it and like
hours watched and things like that yeah
now hulu not known for a lot of uh
original film debuts on on their uh
platform
uh palm springs was a huge that's a
great point that's a great point i stand
corrected they're selective but when
they happen no i wasn't arguing i'm just
saying that they
they
they're not like you know amazon movie
drops where they do these big budget
movies or netflix obviously these
spectacle movies but they have history
they're kind of carving out a niche i
think with these genre films that are
like
there's some good crime
executing the uh sebastian stan fresh
yeah former comedy came out a couple
months ago also a good a good watch but
yeah i loved it
i feel like it's the thing that like
disney can't make on disney plus right
yeah
like hey we own these properties let's
make this version of it over here and i
think that's why we get those special
like one-off quarterly films that are
resonating well i'm still it's sitting
in the back because it's such a weird
time
i've been drinking it i can't it doesn't
help
something's wrong with me now the last
two days have ruined my taste this is
not a great um advertisement for the
japanese barbecue just that you want to
sponsor the show i will be honest this
separately i've had that barbecue sauce
i think it's my barbecue sauce in the
fridge that that sick bastard in the
control room
used to marinate the great kid bastard
in the control room i also want to shout
out you know one thing we we obviously
are in um north america the us here uh
broadcasting live but in other
territories this movie was on disney
plus yeah it was pray in europe i
believe uh
there there is this this debuted on on
disney plus uh and in latin america
possibly
section now is it in
the uk isn't it is it not they've got
star in some and something so like the
places that don't
it makes sense
i think i think in the uk it's
pronounced oolu
[Applause]
have you watched prey on earlier
because they've been making the the
predator and alien comics at marvel for
a little bit before that was dark horse
but now that marvel i mean disney owns
these libraries it makes sense that
they'd slowly bring them over to disney
players i'm wondering how long hulu is
its own separate thing to be honest
[Music]
netflix has uh is now in the deal with
our course right doesn't that netflix
have the exclusive deal with our course
and but when the when marvel bought or
no yeah i understand i was just taking
but i'm curious how this all like ties
into the greater like we've been talking
about you know discovery plus
what the landscape's gonna look like in
five years of like these streaming wars
with these big movies like prey being
straight to streaming yeah yeah yeah and
there were a lot of people saying like
this director's previous work uh
cleverfield lane was thirteen cleveland
yeah that was a theatrical release like
should this movie have been a theatrical
release you know a year two years ago it
would have been obvious how you got to
dump it on streaming service nobody's
going to movie theaters now it feels
like i might have i probably would have
paid 13 minutes to watch this movie by
the way film juice don't start get out
of here phil do not start you're dead to
me film juice yeah you've been dead
you've done enough yeah you have the
correct opinion on prey that you as a
person are dead thank you for
contributing you're garbage you're still
garbage um jessica you wanted to talk
about iron i did want to talk about iron
heart i um i've gotten better at licking
every one of you in the eyes when you
talk
i normally look over here but i like you
guys on the eyes and you guys all have
such pretty eyes and i just want to say
that look at all these gorgeous boys
jesus christ ivan
this is igor
this is and this is eileen
island not isaac
oh yeah well yeah
you know sometimes it changes so yes
iron heart you guys because we saw we
all saw those photos and if you didn't
here they are right now with anthony
ramos and dominic thorne uh that popped
up now we can confirm that he's playing
the hood because it was rumored before
now we know let's get these photos that
hot man
um
let's see dominic
look at dominique dominique sorry i
don't know why i keep saying dominic
dominique oh
well that that's like the full suit and
then there's another or do we have the
other photo
oh okay the suit is amazing yeah looks
sick as hell
i that that suit seeing it now made me
really excited for the series i was
constantly like oh yeah i'm gonna watch
it but like seeing the suit i was like
oh she looks really cool so i was live
tweeting the hall age panel and i got
crap for this tweet but i stand by it i
said that she sounds exactly like riri
williams as soon as she spoke and like
to now clarify people that were giving
me crap on twitter her diction her use
of verbage her flavor of speech the way
she spoke i'm like brian michael bendy's
panel you know how like venice has that
like pentameter and he has like the
certain vernacular he uses as soon as
she spoke i was like we're seeing
williams and i'm so excited and then i
got to talk to her at a party later and
her passion for nailing the way that ben
just delivered that dialogue she
literally studied it like it was
shakespeare so she's i'm so excited for
her portrayal because that character can
go so many different directions and her
dedication to finding that her rhythm
meets bendis's rhythm so excited 100
she's also uh what can you see you can
see her in beale street she's also in um
oh my gosh she's in a bunch of good
things you guys just look into her she's
a great she's an amazing actress she's
also 25. i thought she was like 14. um
so
she was a child i thought she looks like
a girl i was like she's a child and then
found out that she was 25. so her suit
allegedly does look different right uh
in black panther so what we're seeing
here is her mask two suits so we
probably see her prototype and black
panther right have we seen were there
images of her and they're showing it was
just showing her breaking it down
remember the symbol so it showed her
making it that's a box of scraps version
of her shirt
right yeah so i think she's it's
definitely like it has to be the
prototype right and if it is the
prototype does that mean that this movie
or this comes out
before or after black panther no this is
coming out well it comes out but in the
mcu timeline
and the marvel tell me both right it
will be both released after black
panther we're kind of forever and will
be set after are you okay tommy's upset
because oh no
relief
i've been i've been nominated
i've been nominated by the chat to
consume something uh disgusting and
strange john if you can do the dishonors
also real quick corey corey candrilli
i i just want to say i know who you are
i've seen you i i took a picture of you
with my phone
i printed it out
this is you this is
film juice you you know you already know
film juice um but uh yeah we were
talking about uh a little bit about this
also we were saying um
about people that look maybe younger
than they truly are there's a long
history of that in hollywood yeah yeah
yeah it's a lot easier to have a 20 year
old actor than a 16 year old actor play
a high schooler right absolutely labor
laws and you're not on set more than
four hours and you've got to have a
tutor and all that stuff
you guys in the trap fighting i never
said 25 was old i never said it was
young i said i thought she was 14.
i have set up there's a very different
difference between 14 and 20 years
that exists on the spectrum of ages we
have no opinion of it here also i'm
older than much older than 25 i'm also
like age blind like honestly the a
difference between like a 10 year old
and a 20 year old is like
there's people that say they don't see
color i don't see people
well what i'm curious about is in the
comics she's you know like an mit kid
like she gets into the school and she's
like
she's gonna be like that will reach out
no 100 percent like the embassy and
everything else right i i think well it
was that or i think that uh shuri when
she came to like the bay area or what
have you she met her and was like this
girl matches my wings that's what i'm
thinking is like she brings her into the
fold and like they developed the suit
together because i think this suit we
see here is a prototype 100. you think
this is
like two out of like five i think we see
the one she's building the lab we see
this one and then she makes the one we
know from the comments right she also
these photos look like she's like i'm
for example exactly
i think this is mine oh thank you yes
she's in judas and the black massage on
the black side
i have no idea okay sorry to follow-up
questions um i'm so sorry
are we doing a taste or a touch i'll do
you know what i i jump in with both feet
i'll do a taste okay
i'm i'm uh
wait tommy's already wretching by the
way this uh what i'm using for a
blindfold is uh available for sale in
the epic hero shop it's a uh riddler
themed
necktie oh man i'm
ready
getting
smells
open wine oh no
stop talking
stop talking open your mouth
oh god it's on your shirt baby okay
you know i pride myself on my expert
palette yeah
i got elements
of kimchi
yeah pickled cabbage stop right there
but there's also something crunchy
was there something like like a potato
chip element a little bit of that was it
was it was it doritos and kimchi
you're uh you're like on the razor's
edge of being correct
wait
so was it i mean which part is incorrect
it was it was not doritos
okay well i'll i'll ride with
okay was it it felt like a potato chip
and kimchi both the two things i enjoy
yeah they don't go together no and that
was intense yeah oh man that was that
was spicy i could still smell it
it's left the room but still i like
kimchi too but before i realized it was
kimchi the smell of kimchi not knowing
also made me very nauseous kimchi like
uh like fish like a couple other things
are break room no nose yeah okay that
fridge is gonna smell a lot yeah that's
just your your
again it's a delicious food but you're
really putting it on your co-workers
there if you're heating that up or
something um so oh my god i'm gonna i'm
gonna go kimchi and cool ranch doritos
here's what i want from the chat
is is this close enough for zach to win
or or get uh out of the next round it
was uh kimchi with crushed up pocky
chips from yesterday and that's why it
was so spicy
[Applause]
that's gotta be just for this added
spice he's got to be clear oh i hate to
say it because it narrows my eyes
33 more but this is the japanese
barbecue sauce i'm talking about baby
pecans which is uh as means granny
evidently in japanese
i don't know who these people are i have
no affiliation with them but i put this
[ __ ] on everything come on to show you
cowards come on
come on with simu come on with zazzy who
has to be inviting anybody
get everybody out here if you're a
celebrity or iman valani uh we know you
enjoy eric voss come on come on the
break room any any any sauce makers are
welcome on the break room any time
one one thing i was going to say jessica
about the um riri williams pictures i i
did love there was a second picture of
kind of um dominic thorne in like half
the outfit but the rest is the cgi uh
you know thing which we've seen a lot of
images of like robert downey jr and like
those kinds of outfits where it's like
just kind of the thing that goes around
the head but then the rest of it they
see gin which is cool because that's how
they are able to like make that suit so
dynamic and everything like that
jack you're off the hook i just want to
say officially it is now a three-person
race for the next god-awful food
challenge thankfully we're many dollars
away and quite frankly i don't think the
chat has the capacity to put us over 300
we do vote for tom don't you dare vote
for me
yeah he's the one talking
crap these garbage bags have spent their
entire allowances i assure you most of
these health breathers live with their
parents if they don't get five dollars
of internet cash
i love it's just the taste test is like
two random
now i know things stuffed
parameters are yeah okay that i'm never
going to get it and then just i was
going to ask you i am not personally
familiar with the character of the hood
yeah i was going to bring that up next
because coy's here great so the hood is
he was really popular in in the brian
michael men's new avengers avengers era
and he's a street level criminal that
encounters a
i think they're going to use
i think they're going to use agatha
harkness in that vein of mysticism
because there's a lot of characters it
could be but i imagine they're going to
kind of streamline it but imagine an
agatha darkness type and the hood he
wears is an all-powerful ancient
artifact that bestows on him demonic
power also still has guns why i don't
know but he's got these two guns and
demonic powers and he's a hood and he's
really fun for a lot of the blending of
daredevil-esque street-level villains
with your more dr strange's villains
because he can play in all these
different courts and he leads a lot of
ground-level villains by way of his hood
so he's a poor man's kingpin plus a
mysticism two things uh you'll be
surprised in any comic how many mystical
beings use a gun
that's fair it's just such an image of
like all right
it's like i'm still gonna use a pistol
dr strange was john wick
truly truly uh also use that to like
curve the bullet or whatever
she said um and secondly do we think
agatha could also be involved then i
think that's what they'll do right is if
you're gonna have characters in
mysticism i don't think you use anyone
that's going to have scheduling
conflicts like your dr strange's and
your wandas i think they should start
using agatha i even think they might
have dr doom's mom introduced in the
agatha arkansas because dr doom's mom is
so integral to understanding that
character i personally think we're going
to see doom be a foundational part of
phase five and six so the way you wanna
do that is you wanna be invested in him
enough that by the time we get to secret
wars you kind of like that you know him
he's a bad guy but you understand his
people following him so the way to do
that is to endear you to him to the
level that even though he does horrible
things you love him so you have his mom
introduced in agatha darkness and then
you bring her into more things so she's
more relevant i'd put her in okay i mean
i'm long definitely for that it's a long
and that is a long game but i'm
definitely afraid i was going to say
mystical cloak
obviously makes you think of uh doctor
strange and friends uh
we are legally obligated to have wong
show up in every marvel property
contracts so is that how we he could get
this cloak possibly in this uh
do you think they could uh alter his
story his origin
so far to say that he did like train
with wong
i mean that'd be a stretch like he was
like someone that like broke away from
you know the the what's the school uh i
know what you're talking i know and i i
i almost said
i can't i kept saying it as dora melange
and it's not dorky
hey tell me i go to that school how did
they say commercial england it's it i'm
a noise
it's all gone carmitage
you're almost there you're almost there
it's a chemistry
i don't
his name's jimmy he goes to school at
comatose
oh we're polling again
lucia m
shame on you
what kind of uh influence are you on
these people is always colluding with
maniacs in the chat to make us eat bad
stuff as long as you guys vote for tommy
now uh we obviously don't know exactly
what his backstory was and thank you for
that kind of comics background like is
he like he's a criminal who happens to
come across something or is it like the
cloak kind of has a corrupting
power on him like he's a normal dude who
becomes a bad guy i think it makes him
worse i i think you know he's already a
criminal i think he's he wants to be the
kingpin he wants to be can you work with
him
i'll point to you to say it every time
so with all of that being known what do
you think that it's going to look like
if we if if uh in the mcu in their
timeline the black panther comes first
then iron heart in the world what what
would that look like for riri williams
what does it mean is she
like how she said is she working in
wakanda just to become better with like
you know she in the comic book she
really admires iron man and they do this
really interesting thing where iron
man's dead but he's downloaded his
consciousness into an ai and instead of
jarvis downey jr or not daddy jr but
iron man lives in her head and it's her
jarvis but it's it's a fully formed ai i
could see in this i don't think they
should bring downy back that character
is perfect but what if they have her
look up to heroes like iron man like
black panther like like these things
like ms marvel does but she wants to
model herself more directly after them
and therefore she seeks out shuri to get
the wakandan tech and then blends that
with iron man's tech so it's like stark
wakandan tech and i agree with it oh
sorry i was like i agree with that but
then i also just want her to be a woman
that's just like so into stem that's
like i just want to see how far i can
take it but i'd like that i'd like the
idea that she's in stem to build off
multiple things so she doesn't copy one
and that's why i can see her but i i
think that's too close to miss marvel
where it's like i admire these
superheroes let me see what i can make i
want her to be her own woman that's like
oh no
koi oh i came in third that time what
kind of a protective veil is jessica
wearing today you're like teflon
i'm so happy
to see how unhappy jessica is with the
majority of our messing around and
they're like we can't do that no i've
been gone for like three days i also
love like again we don't know the exact
circumstances that riri shows up in
wakanda right we get that great
uh
her handcuff
i mean is it like you know maybe she
gets brought in to wakanda to help or or
she's like 100 but she gets sent back
when what kind of floods
can't keep helping it's underwater i
like her kind of following what bruno
was in the comics where they got like a
grant to go to wakanda to study
it's like a rage scholar but it's like a
wakandan scholar yeah they're gonna
they're gonna start giving out
scholarships soon to people and uh like
in the comics race does not matter
they're gonna like allow anyone to join
you just have to
have a prize
he goes no really listen to the sound of
my chops could you imagine hitting
someone like that they'd be dead
is this so intimidating it is it's also
like the waiting is the hardest part i
think oh okay jessica that's cruel
this is why you should have been voting
for her each time yeah you see what
happened evil jessica get to 400 and
we'll make jessica eat all right
real quick while we uh uh wait for
whatever cruel and unusual punishment
awaits coy a couple of chats we want to
read out uh or uh some polls we ran in
the chat who do you think the joker will
end up with lady gaga as easy beats
overwhelmingly lady gaga yes technically
right i don't think he beats his
character says he beats his characters
interesting no relationships no uh and
then uh does lockjaw make sense in miss
marvel season two if there are no humans
and then overwhelmingly
in humans what did i say you said no
humans i was like what happens
we don't know uh i don't care give me a
big dog
was the most popular yeah find a way to
get lockjaw in there we don't care what
the backstory is uh-oh john has arrived
chef john hi hello everyone no the
fridge has crossed into the threshold of
disgusting it smells very bad oh no oh
that's good for this moment what do we
think koi taste or touch
i mean i'd be a coward to do touch at
this point i can't follow up two tastes
with the touch let's do it i'm taking
dare in the truth
this is messy
i mean you know you gotta get a fork
what is going on
good job oh
he didn't like it oh
chunks oh
i hate it chunky chewy
oh they're talking can you show it to
the camera john what is going on here
sorry hold on let's see if i can do this
no
oh
it's always going to be really dark
because the light is dark it's so sloppy
yeah
what is the first sensation you get it's
like a crunchy peanut butter jelly pie
oh that actually doesn't sound bad yeah
that sounds different i like to eat
spicy chips and kimchi no but it's like
a grape with barbecue sauce no it's like
the most delicious combo ever peanut
butter and jelly no
if you left a pb j in your locker for
six months and then someone put graham
crackers in it and stirred it together
this is also coming from the guy that
eats weird things in movie theaters so i
don't trust anything all right i think
it's in here i think it's peanuts okay
that tastes peanuts okay and it's in
like a
cause that would explain the peanut
butter and i think it's in like a
blueberry pie
is it like a pie with peanuts in it
you're missing one ingredient that's a
weird addition to anything um
you want another taste no
thank you
okay so peanut butter and pie am i right
about those two things someone in the
chat said it's a homemade plate for dogs
with um we are going to have hank eat
everything after this
i'll give you i'll give you since i got
two out of three can i get a hand do you
want a smell yeah okay i'll give you the
smell what a journey i just went on all
right it's under your nose right now
is that just the last ingredient or is
it all the whole thing
what's that it's the whole thing it's
just a bowl of goo
uh artichoke hearts for the win chip
says corey jameson in the chat so i only
got two out of what is the what is the
third ingredient i apologize it is a
store-bought ralph's pie with peanuts
and ketchup oh
honey
you know what was fun about the sundays
as we drew them out john's just making
this johnson's out there frankenstein
the kitchen you know what josh did not
like the ketchup no that's why i
couldn't figure out what because i like
peanut butter and jelly
i think i learned from all you guys that
i if i win i'm gonna touch you know what
john should be ashamed of himself
because he's awful but really more
important who's so close you all should
be ashamed of yourselves wait just stop
put your put your wallets away okay can
we acknowledge that i guess peanut
butter and jelly from blueberry and
peanuts that's not
it helps if you have a general awareness
of what might be in the new rockstar's
kitchen at any given time which i have
less than you guys yeah here i am
suffering from my ketchup
um you know yesterday tommy and i again
don't watch yesterday's episode we're
trying to get it stricken from the
internet yeah but uh i went home not
feeling great i consumed some
foods that don't belong in the human
body uh my equilibrium was all off yeah
and you know what i turned to uh to kind
of rebalance me out
our good friends at athletics oh yeah
okay
we want to shout out athletic grains who
are sponsoring this show all week long
their awesome product ag-one it's like
you know if you have a bad day like a
bunch of trash bag goons in the chat
yeah force you to eat all kinds of
different spicy chips out of pure malice
trying to be better and healthy and
they're like no put a bunch of chips in
your body and burn your esophagus and
then burn your stomach and somehow
you're both high and bloated at the same
time uh athletic greens now this is they
don't advertise that they can fix eating
too many pocky chips and flaming hot
doritos but you know what it worked for
me unless you have a hike planned with a
babe and then you go on the hike with
the babe but you're kind of grabbing
your guts the whole time so she doesn't
know what's wrong with you and you're
like oh sorry i'm just one of those guys
that's so heavy down there so the height
gets all flown out of proportion thank
god ag-1 helped me recover this yes
uh and thank you athletic greens um you
know the great thing about it there's no
need for a complicated cocktail of like
different vita you don't need a bunch of
different multivitamins and all this
different kind of stuff one scoop of
ag-1 and some cold water kind of takes
care of all the vitamin and mineral
needs you need for the day antioxidants
all kinds of good stuff for your brain
for your digestion for your energy your
mood all of that kind of stuff
it's also it's cheaper than buying a
bunch of different stuff uh pennies a
day as they say um and it's super
convenient way to ensure you're getting
what you need into your body not the
stuff you don't need the that the goons
in the chat force you to consume that's
right um there's no goon needs to force
me to consume i'm gonna start referring
to the chat as the dump
the goons
are they dump heads or what are they are
they're garbage they're all driving your
garbage can
so um you know what if if you're feeling
guilt possibly by forcing the uh the
cast members to consume bad stuff or
maybe just because you haven't been
getting the you know the perfect diet in
or you just want to make sure you're
getting the good stuff
head over to get some athletic greens uh
they're good they're giving away a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do visit athleticgreens.com
break room again that's
athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance thank you athletic
green
yeah
[Applause]
all right wow
man i'll be honest cory just going to
just get a rescue the rescue mission got
up was it the hang of it
after the dog that took his fruit snacks
he was eating during that entire battery
because he was like i need to wash it
down i was trying to get in and then he
like came and stole a rapper was running
away with it was crawling trying to be
out of camera don't don't let yourself
get in front of big bang that's right
big hank tank little hanks ah that's
what we just learned there now
listen to me
we're having a lot of a lot of you know
eating and like chuckle chuckle taco
not anymore now it's time for mandatory
fun oh
no that's right anything but this the
graphics so delightful
we play it till it's frightful hit it
again no tommy the graphic
so twisted we play it in case you missed
it hit it again tommy the graphics so
upsetting
we play it till this bloodletting hit it
again tommy no
the graphic that makes you so horny we
play the graphic of anthony ramos again
and again anthony robbins no
yeah okay there we go uncircumcised
villains i like it hood on top what'd
you just say you heard me
thomas he's got a hood tommy
unconfirmed about mr ramos oh no i mean
the character not the actor the actor i
have no personal knowledge can't they
cannot confirm or deny i've never been
at a urinal next to him right now but
i've got my suspicions ah all right
you guys know you do
yeah now ramos
come on the show and show your piece
all right now tommy
i swear to god
she-hulk is almost upon us okay all
right let me rephrase we are about to
get deep into she-hulk oh boy let me try
that one more time you know what
never mind today we are looking at love
interests for she-hulk in a little game
of smash your past now jessica you're
going to take over from here because you
are the queen of smasher pass yeah as
you guys know i'm the queen of smashing
pass and i got a few images here from
she-hulk she helps friends colleagues uh
peers and i'm gonna hold them up and i
want you guys including the people in
the chat to tell me if you'd smash or
pass okay we'll start off a little easy
we'll go with bruce banner hulk smart
hulk if you will and now just just for
clarification i have not played this
game yet i'm not saying she-hulk would
smash your passion no you personally
would you smash or pass great
do you want me to start yeah you can
yeah we can go down the road okay i
personally will pass out of just fear
for my safety i feel like he gets too
excited one of us loses a limb probably
me i don't i don't want to gamble with
like because you know he controls things
now but not always i want to be uh smash
i won't be ripped in half okay whoa
uh call me hulk because tommy smash
there you go
my secret is
i'm always horny
wow that's a that's a three to one smash
that's a three to one it looks like
we're all smashing it
oh my god twice on sunday yes all the
time yes please
i'm i'm begging to be yeah i know we got
punched in the stomach choked out up
until
recently i was fairly certain it was
pronounced tidiana
and i said
smash me till i'm blind
smash me till i'm dead yeah yeah i i
have just a little bit of reservations
only not knowing the what the
character's like yeah character could be
obnoxious because i don't know if she's
a good hang she she likes to fight she
likes her i wanted to hang out
all right
just just from the photos the clips
we've seen very conventionally
attractive wild style uh but i'm i'm
hesitant i just don't know if i'm gonna
find her grading or obnoxious or
whatever we already got three out of
four smashes okay fine smash
i also want like sparring why she'd be
good yeah like for fighting wise you
trained me yeah like a good challenge we
got
jack of hearts in the comic book best
friend some would ship them with
she-hulk uh he's great but he does kill
she-hulk and yeah
i'm a pass because he he's killed and
he'll kill again yeah i just can't i i
can't say i trust it and that would work
like i wouldn't want to fall asleep next
to him 100 percent also was controlled
by scarlet witch and killed everybody on
his team okay good context that's gonna
be a pass for me just name and suit
design alone yeah also my uh ship name
with him like zach and jack yeah he's
like obnoxious you know yeah i don't
know it's too much so i don't i don't i
don't have a universal house a universal
pass on jack of hearts you guys she-hulk
herself of course yes good god because
she has the control i'd be worried about
with hulk but she's also like hyper
intelligent focused and she could teach
me one or seven things and i'd like that
one or seven yes please
jennifer walters smash call me i'm
smashing crush my sternum with your
shaquille o'neal sized foot
smash
smash also i i'm not not for lack of
drawing but i've never uh been with a
woman who's taller than me ah see
that alone is fascinating
in the series you're missing them and
for the other reason that's all for all
the other reasons stated i can recommend
it i try to find women that are
following me that's like my favorite
yeah you are wrestled me and beat my ass
we got porcupine uh who's in the latest
little teaser of uh she-hulk
he's a great babysitter he takes care of
jessica drew's kids he's a really loving
paternal like figure i think he'd be a
gentle lover i want to find out that's
great
i'm passing him uh because his porcupine
oh i'm so sorry no no his porcupines are
just he made them they're like darts
that come out and he also has like
killable gas yeah you can get them out
of that suit
but we're doing them in the suit yeah
and i was going for the man inside i was
going for this soft juicy center
okay i'm on the porcupine external soft
interior smash
nobody can resist a prick smash
oh what about you
oh this is a two passes and a smile i
say it's a pass then it's a passage
okay we'll go a little bit quicker
hellcat best friend of she-hulk in the
comics uh she's connected she's very
interesting she's got a lot of stories
she's lived a bold life i'm definitely
smashing if cat's in your name i'm
smashing him yeah i'm delusional about
[ __ ]
okay okay
we got frog man
you know i feel like
i wouldn't feel good about myself on
like looking back at the roster i'm
gonna pass just i don't i want to keep
the notches appropriate yeah i think
this is also like a kid so i'm
awesome
[Applause]
wouldn't know but he is a young guy that
was like i want to be a supervisor the
chat is thrown smash in hard i do not
you guys know don't do it for mtmg does
not so you can't introduce after showing
us a picture of just a frog person he
might be a kid but yeah
i know that information
i think he i only think he is because
he's basically like syndrome from the
incredibles where he straight up was
like i looked up to these people i want
to be a superhero so i picked a freaking
frog pass pass on it and someone who
earlier said i'm age blind and can't
tell the difference between anybody
i will be hard passing on anybody that's
even close to being young the dazzler
smash that uh forever i mean imagine
what she could do like i want my
downstairs to be a disco ball like there
you go call us call him t swift yeah
get her to play the dazzler of course so
we're all smashing no i'm passing what
i'm not dazzled oh i'm frazzled
these are three passes right no that's a
smash or smashing smashes mass smash
very important smash uh we have
abomination
now which i am easily passing yeah i'm a
pastor
i can't date people that are all over
the place you know yeah you know i get
any consistency in my life
perfect last but not least
daredevil himself
who i would pass
past i'd pass i don't think i could even
joke with it
like i think he's too serious and also
i i love a crime vigilante but i'm also
like
what happens when you beat up someone
that didn't deserve it or like someone
you thought was wrong i don't like just
street fighters unless a street fighter
unless we're talking
but no i i think i'd pass i think it's
just too much for me it's too much like
batman almost interesting
i i don't trust anyone that's too culty
about religion so i'm passing i'm just
saying he's a little too zealous
from boston yeah that's why i know okay
so i've lived through some i've seen
some stuff
uh
man without fear
uh good with his hands quick
uh that's gonna be a smash for me oh
okay well i i think i'm gonna pass as
well it seems like maybe a fun hang i
wouldn't mind him being my personal
attorney but um no i yeah i don't know
also yeah when you need an attorney do
you want to do business and pleasure in
the same way oh good yeah well if
someone said chloe bailey is dazzler i
would die i would have heard oh well
here's the break room
pleasure is ours
i think so yeah uh we've got to go
everybody uh again wait i have to do my
thing i have to do my thing
oh oh yeah we we're we passed the you
gotta eat some oh no okay i'm gonna get
out of here well john forces uh jessica
to eat one one last disgusting thing uh
tommy take it from here you got it guys
before we get jessica to eat this
disgusting thing we want to thank all of
our super chatters for
torturing us today we're waiting for
john uh to bring in the dish
let's talk more about baseball the
detroit tigers no no
acknowledge like
a losing streak
unlike anything i've ever seen before
i'm not sure what's happened i'm not
sure where they could go from here
uh really anything could be going wrong
uh
huh and
uh for me if in the chat you can offer
some solutions we're past the
traditional trade deadline but there is
the uh waiver deadline coming up that's
what are you doing i need to tie
so
uh if you just want to chat some
questions actually you know what i'm
just gonna get my makeup on and i'm
sorry this is taking far too long okay
there we go okay good unprofessional
now i can't see uh
yeah guys sometimes in life
you need to really reassess what you've
been doing for me i've eaten spicy foods
and disgusting foods
i think
i think i gotta
i gotta make a change i also told john
what i'm allergic to yeah so or i said
it out loud i don't know if john knows
read chrissy's super chat okay sorry
chrissy i'm gonna look for your super
chat okay give me a second oh yeah it's
a good idea how do i do something how do
i get to it i can't get to it i don't
know how to get it hey john
it can't have mayonnaise on it okay hey
john if you could actually just delay it
a little more i think we got a good
thing going here
audience is pretty thrilled with what's
going on yep and rapture are you
sarcastic okay
we've got no problem chrissy said funny
story the egyptian word for trash is
pronounced ticket
or [ __ ] it
[ __ ] or tekken i can't read that fire
chuck it in the [ __ ] bucket yeah so
[ __ ] it and check it in the [ __ ] box
like trash bags yeah
i like that that's great
are you doing a taste or a uh touch i
guess i'll touch it you're gonna touch
it
well i don't trust that you didn't put
something i'm not allergic in it i don't
know what you're like exactly that's
what it looks like i don't know okay put
your hands well as long as it's not
mayonnaise
or sour cream because it's like those
dairies that make my first camera i
can't think of a more i said three
things and i see none of those things i
can't think of what is it sour cream
ranch and mayonnaise
this looks vegan yeah no but but i feel
like you're lying and this is like a
process of elimination type thing which
i don't i'm not if ian was in the chat
he could tell you there is uh this is
getting a more dignified way to go out
on the show today than jessica putting
their hands in whatever this is if it
doesn't have the things i'm allergic to
in it so yeah i added something oh that
isn't those things you're still safe
okay again the can i tell you what i
smell yeah hot sauce okay not quite oh
now you get her like clues there's a
clue yeah we didn't get clues we
suffered this this is going to be hard
oh do you want me to just touch open up
open up
wait wait wait wait
oh my god there's so much
there's so much
genuinely what i don't like john what i
don't like is i genuinely really like it
oh no
i have a secret i have a secret this one
was prepared in tandem it was a little
it was a little costa it was a little
beck told yeah it's very sweet okay it's
noodly sweet i know it's noodles yeah
can i keep eating it yeah get in there
sweet and noodles sweet noodles it's not
i've seen elf
okay i'll tell you this too there are
four components to this dish yes you've
got one of them we call it the big four
the big four
salt acid okay i'm feeling the velocity
wow we're doing a velocity test
damn what is that dude
damn what is that spaghetti okay
there's one so we gotta
and um
is it
do you want another bite no i got it
it's in my hand but there's a couple
other ingredients that are not oh oh
spaghetti is cooked but she keeps
sucking you know what i'm saying oh my
god thomas bechtold
i'll say spaghetti and uh sriracha for
now but i know i know what that sweet is
sweet and sour it's sweet sour it's
sweet sour oh my god
damn i know these senses but i don't
know what it is well luckily for you
there's no punishment tell me what it is
i'm mad because i know it but i i can't
it's a spaghetti with japanese barbecue
sauce
and then uh jalapeno and banana that was
the banana oh
the bananas was the secret ingredient
track issues for the rest of their lives
was it worth it yes
we want to thank everybody for super
chatting today we want to thank our
sponsors at athletic greens i want to
thank coy i want to thank jessica i want
to thank zach we want to thank dobson
and austin holding us down with his
expert polling in production we want to
thank john and daschle and everyone at
new rock stars keep it gucci to moochie
and uh you know stay safe and some of
you take chances all right goodbye